I am Dave Ramsey your host and I am
sitting here amazed and appalled amazed
and appalled it was just 20 minutes ago
that you people were struggling through
the Great Recession that the world was
coming to an end
ah don't you remember General Motors is
too big to fail we have to bail out the
banks we have to bail out the car
companies the world is coming down here
the consumer is covered up in credit
card debt
the huge banks are riding off credit
card debt to the tune of hundreds and
hundreds of millions of dollars because
they were failing and the consumer
couldn't pay their bill it was 20
minutes ago this is 2008 this is 2017 oh
it's just the other day guys 2007 2008
2009 you remember all this stuff some of
you do I mean I am getting old that this
stuff is these cycles are coming through
so fast
because it was 20 minutes ago that
consumer debt and the failing economy
was about to bring the entire nation to
its knees
did anybody not learn anything this news
report just comes through Americans now
have the highest credit card debt in
history translation you didn't learn
anything unbelievable consumers just hit
a scary milestone they now collectively
have the most outstanding revolving debt
some roses credit card debts in US
history according to a report released
Monday by the Federal Reserve Americans
had 1.0 to one trillion in outstanding
revolving credit June of 2017 this beats
the
previous record that was set when April
2008 when consumers had a collective
1.02
trillion in outstanding credit card debt
credit card debt revolving credit has
been growing at an annual rate of four
point nine percent one reason is more
consumers are getting access to credit
cards backed by major banks and issuers
in recent months did you people learn
nothing in the banking world that
loaning broke people money is not
working out for you and you broke people
did you not learn anything these banks
do not have your best interest at heart
did you learn nothing nothing I mean
stupid on parade that's what this is and
for the first time since the Great
Recession lenders have given more
consumers with here we go
subprime or below average credit score's
access to credit cards for the first
time in ten years basically there was a
point back there about 15 years ago
where dogs and dead people were getting
credit cards pre-approved in the mail we
had one guy in Virginia signed up for
one fraudulently he shouldn't have done
that but he did he got a credit card
issued sent to his mailbox to the name
buck-naked Rover the dog got one in New
Orleans we got all of these we used to
collect stupid but banks like Wells
Fargo like Chase like Bank of America
that would issue these credit cards
blindly to these accounts and then shake
their head and wonder why they lose
money but they were making so much money
on you people that are paying them so
much interest that they can afford to
write off all the fraud and they could
afford to write off all the bad accounts
where they give accounts to somebody
that's barely breathing doesn't have two
brain cells to rub together which
apparently is a whole bunch of people
just reading this article unbelievable
this year total household debt including
housing auto loans
learned that in the US has surpassed the
2008 peak student loan debts over a
trillion car debts over a trillion not
learned anything they're issuing this
the cards to subprime the subprime auto
market is alive and well now you can get
a nine-year loan on your car at 38%
interest but buddy you got you some
wheels you're an idiot just an absolute
stinking idiot unbelievable
Dave I'll put my credit card offer don't
know if I agree with you really really
and and that's causing you to build
wealth out not at all you know and
here's the deal according to all the
data 9 out of 10 people do not pay their
credit card off every month and
everybody walks around saying they do so
somebody's lying and you're not lying to
me you're lying to yourself because
you're stupid that's who you're lying to
so here's the thing the debit card will
do everything the credit card will do
except gets you into debt I've traveled
all over the world my debit card
I have no issue with it all has the
exact same fraud protections have no
issue with it at all but there's you
know it is no accident that we are at
over the record level now of credit card
debt in the history of the world right
now
unbelievable unbelievable that you
stupid banks didn't learn anything and
some of you stupid consumers didn't
learn anything you're doing the same
stupid stuff and you're going to run
your car straight into the wall NASCAR
engine up in the stands everything's
just completely disintegrated your life
is a shatters because you're doing a
stupid stuff over and over and over
again
wake up America wake up it's stupid on
parade buying crap you can't afford with
money you don't have to impress people
you don't even really like you wander
through target you wander through Costco
you wander into restaurants buying stuff
and buy and stuff and find stuff you
spend like you're in freaking Congress
and you feel the pain not at all you
stick your credit card right there in
the little slot and you type in your
little number or you run it either way
swipe it swipe it swipe it
swipe it swipe it and then can't figure
out why you're broke you make more than
three times as much money as your
parents your lifestyle is six times what
your parents were and you're broke you
make all this money you look good and
you're broke it's because you're stupid
because you're walking around this
plastic in your back pocket thinking
that makes you look like you're somebody
it's straight-up stupidity the only good
news in this is not only will I always
have a job the next generation of
rameses will also have a job
all these Ramzi personalities we're
going to be working at this for decades
because about the time we make a little
headway on it everybody goes back into
stupid like a lemmings over a cliff you
don't know what that is it's a small rap
that runs in Hertz and they run over a
clip when they all get panicked well
there you go
lemming don't be sheeple unbelievable
stupid new record and credit card debt I
just don't believe this this is the Dave
Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]